Sky security and defense analyst Michael
Clark is uh back with me in the studio
Michael we're going to have a look at
what's happening in zapparesia in just a
moment but first of all I want to ask
you about President Biden's assessment
of potential nuclear Armageddon what is
your assessment of that risk we were
hearing from Diana there that many of
the um the nuclear warheads haven't been
taken out of storage as far as we know
no that's correct Samantha I mean Dan is
exactly right if if any of the nuclear
warheads were on the move anywhere in
Russia Western intelligence would know
about it I promise you and they're being
watched like a hawk and so um that's
reassuring yes why that is the case the
Kremlin is trying to Signal it's trying
to keep the nuclear debate going in the
west and it's it's succeeding and so the
Bell garage one of the submarines rather
like this isn't the Bell Robert the
similar class the it's the k329 the
Belgard it's a huge thing 30 000 tons it
left its base in
in the White Sea a few days ago it's now
up in the bear and sea right up in the
Arctic and this carries this enormous
Poseidon nuclear torpedo designed to
create radioactive tidal waves that will
sleet sweep across land masses it's
above water exactly yes and it's on the
surface and so they're showing everyone
they've got it now this is the Belgard
only came into the Russian Navy he was
only commissioned about three months ago
in July so this is a sort of testing uh
voyage that it's on it will probably
test something it may test one of its
Torpedoes or one of its unarmed missiles
but the fact that the Russians are
making it very clear that this this
submarine is now on the move it's just a
way of keeping the tension high and
keeping us talking about tactical
nuclear weapons because there is
obviously a political game going on in
the crimely now a lot of rain fighting
in the Kremlin if they are going for
some sort of talks if they want the West
to lean on Kiev to go in for talks then
keeping the the nuclear issue high on
the agenda is a way of encouraging the
West to lean on Kiev yeah and having us
talk about photographs like this talk to
us about what's happening in Zappa regia
yeah as a parisia I mean this is where
there is a nuclear issue the zapariesian
nuclear plant of course it's quite it's
different from zapparesia the city
they're about 50 kilometers apart 32 33
miles the Russians control zaprasia
Power Plant they now claim because of
the annexation it declared last week
they now claim that that of course is
theirs which it isn't
um and there have been missile strikes
as we've reported in zapparization City
there is there are a series of reports
that those missile strikes have
originated from missiles that the
Russians have fired from inside the
plant those are unconfirmed reports at
the moment but it would make a certain
amount of military sense because we've
always thought that the Russians are
trying to go to the ukrainians into
attacking the plant so that they can
claim that the plant is not safe and
that therefore it's anything that
happens at the plant is is Ukraine's
fault we'll see what happens there but
zaparesia is is now in the crosshairs of
Russian civilian targeting because we
think that the ukrainians may even be
opening or about to open another
military front somewhere in the zaparisa
region put the Russians under even more
pressure interesting so it mustn't take
our eye off what's happening there uh
talk to us as well about what is
happening in the Northeast where we saw
some stunning uh Ukrainian gains there
is it slowing down yes I mean the front
has slowed down a little bit because
Ukraine is I think are repositioning
themselves key area there is uh Kamina
um north of that is uh svatovi and north
of that troiska which is a line that
goes right up to the Russian border and
that's the main communication line from
the Russian side of the border right
down to their forces in the South and
the ukrainians have got those
communication lines now within artillery
range this this war is very much an
artillery War and the range of artillery
is really critical and so the the
ukrainians have now got the Russians
really bothered by uh the lack of
communications and they and they they
are pushing on cremena and they they
will probably we'll see what happens in
the next week to 10 days they'll
probably push them a bit further out and
then I'm guessing they'll swing
southwards meanwhile the Russians are
taking a few Villages near bakmut and
that's mainly the Wagner group it's not
Russian's main forces it's the uh it's
it's their private military company
their mercenaries it's not doing a whole
lot of good because however Far West
they go from back mode they're gonna
They're Gonna Be outflanked by Ukrainian
moves further north so that front is
less mobile than it was but it's there's
an awful lot of artillery going on
interesting so we could see some more of
those yellow hash lines I suspect we'll
see another quite big push in the coming
days but perhaps not this week and what
is happening in Kirsten yeah Kirsten is
where things are moving very quickly
Russian forces have begun to fall right
back and they've they've lost a lot of
territory in the north of the area and
the Russians have been trying to create
a defensive line between and milova and
that line is not holding very well they
have pulled back they've not pulled back
in very good order it seems they've
abandoned a lot of stuff and they're
trying to hold that line and the
ukrainians are pushing them on that line
the reason that that line is important
is because novakovka which is the really
important hydroelectric plant here
controls the water supply to Crimea plus
the road system further on towards
Kirsten novocal kofka is now under real
threat from a Russian point of view and
if the ukrainians are breaking through
that line which they probably are
beginning to do the Russians don't seem
as if they can hold it their novocal
Kafka is in in severe danger for the
Russians and Kirsten is also Under
Pressure there'll be a much tougher
fight for Kirsten because the Russians
will not give that up that's the most
significant City they've taken they
really will fight around it very hard
but that's as that's a separate battle
novakovka is where we're thinking at the
moment